[melancholy music]
It looked like it was finally the end.
This month-long campaign to keep me as the #1 subscriber
to keep me afloat, above the inevitable,
T-Series, a Sub Gap, was less than 15k yesterday.
As closer than it's ever been. It looked like all hope, was lost.
It looked like it was finally it. But then--
[dramatic music]
Something happened. Markiplier and Jacksepticeye--
finally showed up in the final hour, the last second.
*laughing*
"I literally won't shut up until you subscribe to PewDiePie."
My friends who have previously been silent
for a mysterious unknown reasons,
finally decided to extend their helping hand.
God bless you both.
So yesterday we hit uh. 500--
*laughs*
500k subscribers. That's right.
I definitely deserve this. Thank you very much,
*laughing*
You thought that was it, T-Series?
I bet--I bet you they were sitting there with champagne
ready to finally pop the bottle, "Ah geez, this has been obnoxious!"
"Ah, Jeez, this went on way longer than it should've."
NOT SO FAST T-SERIES! I don't think so!
There was a ton of other creators that showed their support as well and I--
seeing it all, it's just been amazing. All the fan support, all the memes--
I absolutely love it.
I know I said, and I still mean it.
I don't care if T-Series passes me, but this is all too fun.
I don't remember the last time I had this much fun on YouTube.
It just--everything has been insane.
It all started with Mr. Beast creating the billboards to tell people to subscribe to me.
Mr. Beast: "Ey! Uh, what's this one say again?"
Offscreen: "Subscribe to PewDiePie for original content"
Mr. Beast: "His content is SO original!"
Which then inspired my fans all across the world to do the same, hand out flyers, put up posters...
Justin Roberts bought the biggest billboard in New York City--
*laughing*
Justin: "IT'S THERE! OH MY GOD IT'S UP THERE."
Offscreen: "Oh! There it is!"
Justin: "We did it! We did it, it's up there!"
"Subscribe to PewDiePie right now guys!"
Davie504 played "B*tch Lasagna" for 10 hours straight!
*laughs*
[Davie504 playing B*tch Lasagna]
HackerGiraffe hacked 50k printers to tell people to subscribe to PewDiePie
Definitely a worthy cause. The amount of attention this is getting is just absolutely insane.
Everyone seems so caught up, everyone seems so invested to this "subscribe to PewDiePie blah-blah-blah--."
--and I honestly feel like I don't deserve it.
I feel really weird about it, but it's a blast nonetheless.
You've probably seen these live streams where it's PewDiePie vs. T-Series and uh--
Everyone is just so--invested into this.
But there's a part of this that I really, really don't like
But--and it's a shame because I--
it is a vast majority of people,
but at sometimes, in these comments--and you guys have told me this as well,
you see comments such as like, "F**k Indians" or "F**k Indians 'c-word'."
Just really distasteful, unnecessary comments.
And I obviously made Indian jokes and stuff like that, but I do that of all countries and--
--this is is not what I'm about,
and I know my fan base isn't about this either.
I'm getting more attention now that I'll probably ever get.
And I feel really weird about it as well, so why not just take that fact and
redirect it to something more positive?
And show that this fan base, and this group of people can do something positive as well, because I know we can.
No more, "F**k India."
Let's instead help India.
Maybe you already knew this, or maybe you didn't,
but there's over 10 million child laborers in India between the age of 5 and 14,
and even more between the age of 15 and 18.
Almost 23 million. That means that almost 1 out of 10 kids in India are working.
Now, this is mostly in rural areas,
but this means that, a lot of kids in India are missing out-a chance for a proper education,
and a chance for a proper future.
That's why I decided to create a fundraiser for the charity called "Cry."
"Cry" is a charity that focuses on making a better future for kids in India.
The reason I picked "Cry" as a charity, is because
they recognize that just rescuing these kids won't be enough.
So they instead work on identifying the root causes for these issues to solve them.
Children, for example, work mainly to help their families, and because there's a high demand for child labor.
But Cry setups strategies to prevent these issues,
and uproot them to build a better future for all of India.
I think it's a great cause. I would highly encourage you to donate.
I created a fundraiser down in the description.
Please do check it out, and donate. Any bit will help.
I will of course donate as well.
And tomorrow between 4pm and 7pm UK time,
I will be live-streaming, where all the proceeds will go towards raising funds for this charity.
Let's do something cool. I think we can turn this around and make it something really cool and really positive.
Let's actually help 9-year-old kids in India. (Felix, we love you for what you are doing.♥️ ~India.)
That's it thank you for listening.
Bye.